there were no kids on Newsradio right
there were no were there any lifetime
there were there like act they're no
they're all they were all adults yes all
adults except Mandy dick index just
whatever he is yeah yeah yeah yeah I ran
him at The Comedy Store the day he will
not the other day he's not he's banned
now is he banned yeah he licked Earl
Skakel's face and he just would there's
drunk Andy and when drunk Andy's around
you just gotta get the [ __ ] out of there
you know you can tell the difference
it's two different guys very aggressive
yeah gets like bangs in the car window
oh no it's drunk Andy yeah and and sober
and he's a [ __ ] sweet wonderful guy
and so funny man he's a hilarious guy we
we did scenes together where we had to
do the take five six times because I
couldn't stay straight yeah kept
cracking yeah well you can't stay
straight with Andy yeah but he is he is
he's so funny but I had I did a I did a
early one of my first things I did have
like a voice on American Dad
and I did they had me do Andy Dick and I
was so psyched to get a gig you know and
I mean I was like I'm not my favorite
thing is not doing other comedians like
there's some weird kind of code that I
don't know what yeah you know what I
mean you feel like a dick I try not to
talk [ __ ] about comedian it just it's
like I don't know why it's like I did it
it was one of my first gigs it was like
oh cool I gotta be on American Dad I did
Andy Dick I was looking back I would not
probably do it now where you know you do
it over the top I don't know I just
didn't I don't know I mean isn't Andy
Kahn over the top as you know what I
mean like yeah I did not mean it was not
been like I'm gonna go [ __ ] get Andy
Dick but anyway when I saw him when I
since then I've seen him over the years
and and I like him and I think he when
he is sober he's like you know I saw
your impression of me
and he's like and he's kind of like it's
funny you know and then I've seen him
drunk and he's like so you know it's a
very different
it's a very different version of it and
I'm like oh but you know and but I get
it man if someone did a [ __ ]
impression of me on some animated show I
don't know I probably I'm like now I'll
do the impression of me you know let me
let me control my narrative here I think
you got to take your lumps I guess so if
you dish them out you got to take your
lumps yak